this is the harpies on The View running
cover for not only Hunter Biden who's
basically ignoring and disassociating
from his biological daughter
but also Joe Biden who apparently wants
nothing to do with his granddaughter and
there's just so many things wrong with
this watch
and scarring hit one of his
grandchildren's lives by not publicly
embracing her so apparently his son
had a baby with a woman they've thought
about it and he pays for the for the
baby but he has not embraced the child
so Maureen down is saying it's bad for
the child that the president has not
acknowledged her
so I
I kind of think well that's a she should
be clenching at
the son whose baby it is it's not the
president's baby so I don't know what
you think but I'm throwing it out I
agree with you completely it shouldn't
have been uh it's uh
directed to Joe Biden should be directed
to Hunter Biden it's five children not
four Hunter because this is not Joe
Biden's baby and I think it's very hard
for Joe Biden to be a grandfather to the
child if his son is not being a father
he can talk to his child he can advise
Hunter but look what is what is
absolutely evident to me is that the
right wing and the Maga world has
decided to weaponize Hunter Biden
against his dad yeah and everything and
anything Hunter does or does not do is
going to be weaponized and Marine
doubted you guys get it you guys get it
and even Alyssa Farah there at the end
who's the supposed conservative but
she's nothing but a highly paid hack
they run cover for Democrats there is no
reason that Joe Biden and Jill Biden
cannot have a relationship with their
granddaughter he is their biological
granddaughter Hunter Biden may be a
crackhead and an evil bastard and God
whatever else you want to think of
Hunter Biden but that does not mean that
Joe Biden as the grandfather think about
that there are probably hundreds of
thousands probably I wonder if you could
even run numbers on this probably
hundreds of thousands of grandparents in
the United States who are taking care of
their grandchildren night right now
because of parents who have passed away
who are not psychologically able to who
are addicted to substances whatever
because their parents have to work in
other areas whatever the reasons might
be you now have the most privileged
family in America the guys the freaking
president of the United States they are
all worth millions and millions of
dollars the sun is a drug addict and
everything else he most likely left
cocaine at the White House last week
which by the way the FBI and CIA
officially as of this morning they're
just saying now nope we're just done
we're not even gonna look any further
into figuring out whose it was so I'm
pretty sure we know who's it was
um and they're they're concern mostly is
that this is about the right wing it's
about what the right wing will be doing
as I said the other day just imagine
if Donald Trump Jr who doesn't even
drink by the way I've been out with him
many times he does not even take a sip
of alcohol much like his dad doesn't
take a sip of alcohol imagine if he was
a crackhead and imagine if he had a
one-night stand with a girl and then
wanted nothing to do with that girl and
then Donald Trump it publicly came out
that Donald Trump wanted nothing to do
with his granddaughter imagine what the
people of the people the the harpies The
Witches the wenches of the view would be
saying about Donald Trump and Donald
Trump Jr
[Music]
sir